Unknown: Do you have two offices because you interface with different people? So yes, I interface with quite a few people and so most of my direct reports are doing engineering work. Water please.
Unknown: Yeah, I'll just take water as well. You just like water? Double water. Extra water? Two fisted.
Unknown: I have frozen water in my water. And so I have service responsibility and the service team is upstairs and I report to Jason. He's upstairs. Okay. And so there was a point where we were moving some team members into some spots that were, down there and they're like, okay, it makes sense to move down here. And Jason's like, nope. I'm like, okay.
Unknown: This was like a week before the office was done though. Like you were like.
Unknown: Yes. I literally tell him on a Thursday. I'm like, I said, hey, do you want to let you know I'm moving? Just so you're not surprised. He's like, no. I'm like, I think kind of one hand the number of times he has literally said straight out no. And I was like, okay. I was like. Well, can you just go negotiate wherever you want me to be? I'm totally fine with that. So he and Josh, like, negotiate through what happens. He's like, all right, you will spend some time downstairs, and you will spend some time upstairs.
Unknown: That's because he wants that quick answer. Why do you need to negotiate an elevator between the two or a fireman pole? As long as they're on top of each other, I don't mind.
Unknown: I just want to be able to get up and down with a slingshot. So now I have office hours that are on, this is where I'm upstairs, this is where I'm going to go out of here. Wow. If you took over Chris Rock's office, what's it there was.
Unknown: California. Oh, that's true. Very, very important.
Unknown: A slide that goes out the window of one. That would be, I'd be down for that.
Unknown: Oh, God, perfect. What did she get? Yeah, I designed this.
Unknown: Oh, that's what she got last time. I had three meals out of that. Oh, I had two. I went home, I had a meal, and then my wife had it. I think I can't get it this time because it won't save until I get home on Wednesday. She loves elevators like that too. Are you guys staying in town? I'm staying in Andy's house. He's got a newborn. Yeah. I got to get the girls ready for school. My newborn is seven months old now, which is just a really, just a really, just a super evening. We'll ride an elevator, and we will go to this one. It's so true.
Unknown: Well, Jason, it helps me do the Tyler tour. First one? Third one. Oh, third? Yeah.
Unknown: So the other two girls are great, but we've learned, like, number two, can't, cannot stop touching them. After we did it, though, he was like... I don't know what to do with that. Soft spots.
Unknown: Anna's worst fear is that they're going to, like, poke in the soft spot. Yeah. It's most of the time. It freaks her out. I know. We're still working on it. I'm like... I was like, what's that? Like, that's the plates coming together.
Unknown: If you tell, if you tell the kids not to touch that, now they know it exists, and they want it. Yeah. So I'm afraid of heights.
Unknown: Go on. So you're responsible... Three turtles. The Burj Dubai, and going out on the catwalk up there.
Unknown: Too small. How small is the catwalk? How human? Are you a human? How old are you? You are not. That was just too much. I don't get to do it. Okay. That's the Burj Dubai. I went on a walk and they haven't worked it out. So you don't get to the top part because the top part of it is actually private area stuff.
Unknown: The youngest, he's seven, almost eight, and he has been able to learn so much from his brother.
Unknown: You go in the elevator and go so fast.
Unknown: You're hearing your ears go off as you're going. You're like, oh my gosh, that hurts. Steve, you got the Hawaiian bowl? Okay, I'm doing it. I'm going to do the Hawaiian pork bowl. That looks really good. Yeah, we'll get it ordered and then I'll kick off the order business. Where's my broccoli bowl? These guys.
Unknown: Yeah, literally. Someone needs it. This is the problem with all three of us being inventing. Oh, Brooklyn Nine-Nine. by the way. Which is? A TV show.
Unknown: Okay.
Unknown: That's my point. Oh, yeah. I said you asked. Oh, yeah. That's good. I said 9-9 once. Can you help me understand why? Your guys' sandbox? 9-9! Yes. You've seen your people in your sandbox? Sam did it. Oh, that's just a thing? Yeah. Or Seinfeld. What's the current? I like Seinfeld. Seinfeld, I'd be down with it. Oh, did I hear it's Friends right now? Yeah. Oh, yeah.
Unknown: That's why Rachel Green was in it. I don't think a lot of people at Blackpool watch Parks and Rec, though. Oh, man. You like me some Ron. Arrested Development. So good. I like me some Ron. Okay. So, Arrested Development. From Parks and Rec. Good. But Ron's not great.
Unknown: I love it. It is too niche. It's one of those I've only seen like once or twice. I didn't know they didn't allow it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I did not. Oh, yeah. I heard it afterwards.
Unknown: So, that relationship is... There's dozens of them. Yeah, yeah. It's just so fun. Yeah. Ron is so not around when she's around. Yellowstone. Bird Happily. Go to Grand Canyon. Two years. There's so many good characters. What's the marketing guy? He's crazy. I forgot his name, but you know what I'm talking about? Tom. Oh, no, Tom. He is one. You're right. I'm thinking of his friend who always sings things. Oh, Don Raphael. Yeah. And Mona Lisa. Money, money. That one would be really good. There's some strong characters in that one. Treat yourself. We did a treat yourself, treat yourself.
Unknown: Oh, nice. And Josh was like, what? Like, he had never heard of it. And I was like, people will think this is hilarious.
Unknown: I can't believe you don't even understand my genius right now. Oh, that's a good idea. We're genius together when we talk about things. You start off, and then we wrap. That's great. Like, family feud, pulling the whole block image. Did you read it? No, you can't do it. He's like, he's not hearing about it, but it's in there.
Unknown: Sam! Yeah, I'll try.
Unknown: Like, I heard you were at Wired the other day. I told Laura, I was like, you settled for this, Fred, when you had Sam right there? Did I say Jairo? What do you mean.
Unknown: I just pulled it out of my pocket. Jiro. Isolated. Jiro. That's what the people said. Cool. We didn't know that. That's what they said. I guess my mom is, like, 100% Greek. She says things more even single-accented than I do. She'll say, you know, she'll say, feta. Which is randomly. Like, that's not... She'll speak without a single accent. She has no accent.
Unknown: But then some of those words, she has to say them. And we were sitting outside in this local place. Okay, alright, so, um, they came out to bring our food. And apparently at some point, Steve had gone in and had a little side conversation with us. They come out to bring our food. The lady goes, um, alright, Sam, are you gonna be... I'm gonna see you guys tomorrow morning and you can have a cup of your bread.
Unknown: And I was like... Everybody stops. Steve's seen, like, a series of videos where it'd be a person saying the same word in a different language. And Emily's like, did you find bread here? And, like, take it to her and make a sandwich for her.
Unknown: No, it's always, like, salad or whatever. And then she followed up with that real quick. I'm so sorry, I can't do that. Why not? It's hilarious.
Unknown: It's not personal. It's a good joke. It's not personal.
Unknown: And I was just like, I didn't know what to...
Unknown: And I was like, I didn't know what to do. She hit me, she literally struck me. Good thing she doesn't work at Block Imaging anymore. She's still on payroll. I am. Oh, she's a contractor. No, she's still on payroll.
Unknown: Because I have to keep my FSA. FSA, thank you. FSA, I just got out of, like, Engineer World. So they're recruiting me now, which is really nice. Otherwise I'd lose three grants, and it would go back to Block. Not back to Block. It didn't come from Block. It came from me.
Unknown: I don't think it goes back to Block. They keep it. Oh, it goes to Block. Yeah, I think it goes to Block. I think the company, like, facilitates work.
Unknown: I don't know what the rules are, but I'm not going to say in ten years. But it used to be, week one, you could go to Block. Whatever we called it. And quit a week later and have Block. No, definitely not. That happened to me at Block. I know you could.
Unknown: I quit in July. Chad did me a solid, Dr. Chad. I wouldn't.
Unknown: There was like a weird stat about me, it would be that I could look at most TV's and I'd be like, what are we talking about? That's a funny one. He was like, I love you. I'm sorry. I've had seven good TV's I've had. Two by the perfect TV. This is when I was single and had time. I love to splitter. I try to watch the same section go to the rings and all the different areas.
Unknown: And I would just talk to Steven. We'd be talking all the time and then he'd ask a question about Nick's coaching. And the new guy was like, oh, what are you going to coach? Oh, I'm soccer. Right now, like a lot of soccer. And I was like, oh, I'm soccer. Oh, I'm soccer. Yeah.
Unknown: Why? Because you just wanted to. I played soccer. I was obsessed with it. I just like, if I'm getting something, I want to get the best. So I now have the last stand. You're like, I am not that old. I am not that old. Obviously, LG and the Ledge brothers and I, we were like 22, 23 at the time. The people over at Drake's were basically the same.
Unknown: That's a Ledge blue light. Which you can adjust to the color tone. But you'll never get the option of doing that. Well, you know how cheap I am. I think I told you when I bought my TV. I bought an LG 300 or something. It was a long time. Yeah. It was one of the best. Which for me, like, but then now any of my friends or my parents just bought a TV from Costco for 300 bucks and I look at it and when you're not looking at it side by side, I'm like, that does look pretty good. But then I'm like, it is insane.
Unknown: It's just so. Yeah, the latest couple have gotten a lot better. Yeah, it's so good. It's so good. That was the thing that blew my mind. It's like movie love. It's like, yeah, it is. What's funny is that so many times I've watched TV, I can't remember if I watched it on my iPad or my big screen. And like, after it's done, it's just kind of in your brain as a story. You can talk right into it.
Unknown: Are you recording or not? Everything. Oh, go ahead. Go ahead. We basically get this and then do transcriptions per speaker, so we can all look back and that's how we knew the domain needed so well, we took everything that you did on the videos, extracted the text, put it in the chat, and then put it into a video, it's so tiny, it.
Unknown: lasts 30 hours, but what's really useful, we'll be able to go back and say I took some notes and I know Sam said something, this has got to be in there, we'll search for that and say okay, what's the thing that you said it's got to be in there.
Unknown: Can I do the whole thing, but I'll do Noah as a guy, you were here, you guys were here.
Unknown: Isn't there an agenda, a secret mission for this meeting, because I thought this is the.
Unknown: only time we have PB, you can get more time, no one has said hey, would you join us.
Unknown: I literally have it on my calendar, we have at least six recorded moments where we said we need something and they're like the only person that can answer this is Paul and he refuses to pick up. Oh, that's true. That's true, too. Both. Both are true. You didn't ask, and I won't pick up. Oh my gosh. So that's what I... I'm pretty sure there's some summary of that, or at least we can tell AI to tell us that back. We're in a logic loop. It's also recorded on their AR that they weren't the first choice for rendering.
Unknown: He intentionally said that, just so it'd be in the AR. Yeah, there's quite a few things that are currently under record. Let me kick this... Let me get you guys up to speed and kick this up. We've had seven hours of very productive time. Yesterday was focused in the first couple hours on external. So it's sourcing the window, sourcing the user. And I believe they walked away with saying, oh, slam dunk. We can certainly provide all the things that we've talked about. And then we started talking about internal today.
Unknown: Erica Smith joined us. Allie was there. And the two team members here. Their eyes got really big. What problems they can solve of Salesforce. We're looking really for guidance on where is the potential consequence of working in motion already with F&D. Does this make sense what's being mediated right now? And are we on the right track or are we missing something? It's a big conversation and I want us to kind of kick this off with you two being the sponsors and also on 360 approval team.
Unknown: You're going to probably give them and us the best advice. And Mark's not available because he's in the middle of the office.
Unknown: And just so I understand, we have uncovered now that to launch the new customer external facing wouldn't require us to touch much within Salesforce.
Unknown: There's a couple of things we would need to know where things live. Like which things specifically? Like parts. Like system's own data.
Unknown: Yeah. But you're right about that.
Unknown: Okay, because one of our biggest concerns was that we would have to push the date back for the external launch because it would break everything in Salesforce. But it sounds like that's not the case. No. And so we can move forward with momentum to get it out to external users, ASAP, and then our phase two would be focused on our team so that we could really take our time and create the efficiencies we're looking for without having to wait.
Unknown: And you're saying that piece, you're talking about pulling out of city. Or at least finding the things that could be pulled out. Things that could. Taking your time to find the right thing to pull out, yeah. Those are the things we started saying, but we weren't sure if it was allowed.
Unknown: Here's what I think I hear you saying, and I have a picture that I can't really scratch that. I love this. I'm a visual person. So right now within Block, we're going to say that there's three things that are very entangled, which is Salesforce, sourcing window, and power tools. Power tools are things that make Block's life easier. But not necessarily, they're written in Salesforce, but they're not necessarily. your tiering system.
Unknown: A feature that's a differentiator for you guys.
Unknown: Yeah, it's something that is not specifically Sourcing Window. It doesn't have to necessarily be Salesforce because it's not data-centric and it doesn't map to accounting or whatever. Because Salesforce is an enablement platform for the technology to exist across the system in similarity, but this power tool doesn't have to necessarily exist there. It should exist here. Well, it depends. Certain things that are product, and that's the distinction, is that Sourcing Window is a product that is available and powerful for many people. A power tool is a product that is specifically a block enabler,
Unknown: and Salesforce is the technology enablement for systems in block to all speak the same language. The clear delineation, all these lines, when these lines are done by brilliant decisions in engineering and strong APIs and infrastructures and the right way to do it, there's no difference. There's less and less confusion. And the better that these, and maybe all power tools end up in sourcing window because there's a value proposition to making those possible.
Unknown: And we've talked about what that can look like, but as it stands, certain things are, very interlaced and the more we can say, all right, well, what's the first way we can demonstrate, the power of what sourcing window as a standalone tool can be. And then what does it look like for us to make great decisions to pull these things without people losing functionality, to allow the right onboarding experience, to, to not make sourcing window into just a power tool for block that it can't sell unless it really.
Unknown: wants that to be, which would be a good business decision because there's, or could be a good business decision. It could be like, you know what, at the end of the day, we just, we just need a really great power tool. I mean, we're going to make it so good that our vendors want to be on it and that it is what it is. But that's probably what I, what I'm, so what I'm affirming that you said is yes, we think there is a clear way. To pull. the external pieces out and that is that that does exactly this but it is part of this whole what we've been what got confusing today and what we were digging into is does does block have a.
Unknown: strategic direction on this currently or do they just need to see what this looks like first before we start deciding what power tools belong where and what the possibilities are what the benefit.
Unknown: is what does it look like what are the does that make sense I don't want to over I think so so I want to give clarity I'll let them override me if they they think it differently the way I look at it is this tool should be completely separate of what it is and we're coming in along any other customer we just get privileges as the customer yeah that you need to integrate with our system and here's the things we need to integrate we need to have a tiered system we need to be able to do this we need to do this and we need to present it here that our team is working in it which will be.
Unknown: something we'll have to do in the future and that's what we're trying to do and that's what we're going to have to do in the future anyways, when we go into CMMS systems, because they're going to say, great, we work out of this, present it here for me. Yeah, yeah. And so, if we go through that piece and that viewpoint is, let sourcing window be totally external, and we are just any other customer.
Unknown: we're just the number one most important customer you have. Yeah, that's a really critical delineation that I'm thankful for, that was the perfect way to do it.
Unknown: Okay, so here's my other.
Unknown: Where that fits great is, okay, so the sourcing flows make sense of a sourcing window. Well, those are built on capabilities, so we're moving those over to sourcing window, where capabilities are built on materials. We probably don't want to move all materials over to sourcing windows, because that's global, but that could go either way. And then, while we're on that topic of materials, customers are regularly creating and validating materials. So, do we have some materials that are in sourcing window and some are block materials? And when there is overlap, how do we,
Unknown: how does ownership work.
Unknown: Well, if block is a, customer of this, then they could hold Sourcing Window accountable to having a master materials list that is valid and up to date. Which is the dream.
Unknown: That's what I think the best place there is.
Unknown: But then that means you are kind of maintaining two, and you're approving the update. Well, there will be synchronization for sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Is there a way to apply it in sync? So hey, you don't have this.
Unknown: Right. Approve. Okay. Yeah. But what you said is my preference. Yeah. It's our preference. Right.
Unknown: 100%. Yeah. It's the cleanest way to do it, and then we have these synchronization processes. So it's helpful, but where it gets tricky is, is there a desire to update the same record object in both systems? Could that happen.
Unknown: Like let's say a material. Yeah.
Unknown: Is there a reason to update the material? I'm not even sure at all what attributes you might update, but you update it in, you know, in our system, you update it in SFC, and update it in 360.
Unknown: We're only talking about changes to the characteristics of the record, and not anything to do with inventory load or anything like that. That happens on the establishment of that record. That's what I was hoping, okay.
Unknown: That type of adding functionality has to exist for customers, too, because they're going to have their own inventory that they're trying to sync.
Unknown: I think what Paul was saying is exactly what we were hoping you would say, which is we build it agnostic, and then you guys get the first and best integration. You could sell integration packages to everybody else if you wanted to, but you always have the competitive advantage.
Unknown: That is a question. We knew about a basic user. We knew about an eventual premium customer, a premium vendor. What we imagine is Block is a super vendor, a super customer. With automation. It is a super premium, whatever you want to call it, but that's the way that we would build it. Is that something that you ever in the future could imagine another client having? That is the best answer. That is exactly what we want to get. Yes, build it as if someday we might want to give other people this much power.
Unknown: That really allows us to... Focus in on this user, this user, this user. Because what you're saying, in my mind, you're saying sourcing window becomes one of its powers is the Materials Master Record, one of its value propositions. Right now, we would just pull Block's current state and then sourcing window, however you guys want to have the entity, what administrative personnel would be overseeing, would be your responsibility. It becomes a part of the experience to keep that brilliant and up-to-date in interfacing with this super premium user, right?
Unknown: Yeah. And then a value proposition in a lesser degree to the premium user and then to some degree to the basic user. They don't get the preferential treatment, but they get the benefits of what the other users are paying for. That makes a ton of sense. That clarifies a lot for us. Now, the strategy of what you want for Phase 1, 2, 3 is your thing. And what I was going to say is, is... I had originally told you what I would really love to have is phase 1, 90%, phase 2, 70%, phase 3, 50% or whatever.
Unknown: That's what I said in the kickoff. Like confidence level. Confidence level. I have since, and this could change over the next two weeks, but I have since said part of me wants to lower our confidence level for phase 2 and phase 3 so that we can learn to work together and build something great and be like, oh, now we have clarity of direction and we've seen how the interaction works for all of us, then let's just kind of say, well, in general we're thinking this and this, but it's like 25%. It's like basically we think that we would like this, but then that last, as we get into, it could be two months from now.
Unknown: It could be three months from now. When you start seeing actually things happen, then we'll take a step back and say, well, let's have a couple focused meetings and build this out now that we've worked together on some things. We've seen the interactions. We've seen what it looks like to pull something from there.
Unknown: That's crazy. Phase 2 and phase 3. You want to understand. enough so that you don't make decisions that are going to make your life harder once we get there. You want to understand it enough, but not, you can figure out all the specifics.
Unknown: I would say I'm less, I'm less concerned with us and I'm actually more, more interested in you guys fully understanding what things are possible. I want you guys to be like, Oh, that's what you meant when you said that. Cause I actually feel like we're pretty confident in what things are going to look like. There are some integrations like, but we've worked, we've integrated with lots of different people. Everybody's nice here. We're pretty confident, confident that's going to go well.
Unknown: And I would, I would lay another layer onto that is that there's, we're making a big investment in conversations right now. Within the industry, that's a lot. And that's enabling them to be able to make better decisions on product.
Unknown: And those things should be true in non-medical. Yeah. Not even medical. I need, there's, it has to be a piece of you in the back of your brain that says, if I put this in farming equipment, it works. It works. If I put this in the auto industry, it works. Think of all the scrap yards that are out there. What if they could all connect and all of a sudden do some things together and we just built them a platform that they could go in and do it? In all of those places, like I think about data management and that the only thing that really matters significantly to be able to connect with every other person's thing is part number.
Unknown: How do we establish part number? I don't care about description. The tool can have this description, and I can have this description, and they can have this description. It's fine, but what's the most number one, most important thing? It's part number. Because a part number is a part number is a part number. That's the key when we're looking at things. The rest we can kind of figure out what everybody wants in doing those things. But if I have that part number and my description's off, it's fine. There's no trigger. Oh, you don't have this part number. Do you want this part number? Okay, let me look at it. Oh, yeah, I do. Okay, I want to say this, this, and this. I don't want to say it like they are because that's not how our team looks at it and views it and sees it.
Unknown: But I can still have a match that can tie, and we're fine. Yep. Sure, why not.
Unknown: Who? Andy Brown with Purchase. The monitor guy. I want to have some talk with them about AI and what Purchase is doing with it. Oh, they're doing that? They're the leader right now in tech science. That's a challenge accepted.
Unknown: What's my passion? Naming things. Which one.
Unknown: Oh, chicken farmer? Oh. Is it a goal? Yeah. I'm trying to guess. I don't know. I'm the hero.
Unknown: I got it. I'm the hero. I'm the gyro. I'm Greek, so that's not how we say it. What else.
Unknown: I feel like we're more on the same page. Even more, much more, we seem to be very aligned. A lot of what we've been talking about is, before we started talking about user personas, we said the star of the show is the part. The part has a journey. The part is the... Yeah. There's a central element that allows all the different workflows to be organized together so you don't have to show a million things. You can say, oh, this part was bought, this part was installed, and oh, it was DOA, and then it wasn't. The part owns all of that information.
Unknown: Yeah, I'd also think as you create that structure, because we always know there's going to be dirty data added, how do we combine data that then it can still flow and have relationships inside of it? Because, and again, suggestions like, you're putting in this, did you mean this? Because there's a ton of data associated around this. Oh, that's the part I meant. Yes, I want that one.
Unknown: You guys said this concept of part assemblies, where parts contain other parts, and essentially other parts. Relationships to parts. Thank you so much.
Unknown: There's also the relationship to... Hawaiian.
Unknown: Okay, you have to have a width kind of thing. Steve said it was good last time, so... What's that? The Hawaiian mold. I didn't get the Hawaiian mold.
Unknown: I just know I'm going to need it. I was telling you, we went out to dinner, and I'm like, I think I used six now. No, not yet. All right.
Unknown: Oh, this has, like, cinnamon. What is this? Yeah, this is in, like, a choice of things.
Unknown: We make the broccoli bowl at home now. Yeah. That's pretty easy. She's doing it.
Unknown: My wife wanted me to pop me up there, and all I did was I just had my menu, and I put everything in a separate pile with rice in there. Literally everybody did a bowl.
Unknown: Yep.
Unknown: It's all the same stuff.
Unknown: I'll take some barf, please. I'm the winner. You guys want to take a sip with the adults here? Oh, yeah, yeah. I normally eat a lot of that. Everybody's being so sure. Steve, when you talk about part taxonomy, what does that mean to you specifically? Creative in their decision making. Like, how would you use the name of it.
Unknown: Yes, yes.
Unknown: All the elements that go into a name, I got you.
Unknown: And then you've got three major manufacturers out there. I wish I did it more often. I've tried it. I've tried it periodically, watched my son do something. 150 other medical ones say, wait a second.
Unknown: Do I know VINs have actually like a checksum digit where you can tell if you've got it right or wrong, your part numbers? Nice. Is there even an easy way to, like I said, I mean, I had to deal with a lot of cleansing of master data when I was at Botch. And so the different ways to say this already exists or you entered it in a valid part but not long enough, missing the right, like this should be an A or B or a C. That's where we could have better, cleaner data if we validated it smartly. Okay.
Unknown: I like that. Those are the things, though, that if defined, like, are easy. If need to be discovered. Like, I don't know how some of these things, I don't know how we hold the scale. How what? How we hold the scale. Like that. That could be a simple problem. That could be a very big problem. Yeah. It's a.
Unknown: I'm hoping, I think anyone can decide the idea of how to tie it to this. Because that, you're right, that could be simple length validation. Or it could get a lot deeper.
Unknown: BioMed is just PDI, another platform where you can just... Yeah, and the goal is to be transactional and say, okay, let's just use the parts we have. And then later, if you want to enhance it, okay, let's start with that.
Unknown: Anytime that it's like in a comfortable situation, or like, oh, I'm going to lose some comfort if I do this, I'm going to make myself do that.
Unknown: You can't hold a report on how many parts they actually used. It was good to get that established.
Unknown: But the potential part numbers, wow.
Unknown: You're right, and that's where architecturally, I want to make sure I build it in a way that we take advantage of the small things when they're small. We don't get to ourselves in trouble when they get big.
Unknown: You're going to say better than our Mediterranean place down the road? Yeah.
Unknown: Oh, it's very different, it's a different kind. It's not very comfortable. What's the name of it? It's literally around the corner. The Mediterranean face, do we call them? They do, yeah.
Unknown: El Burrito. It looks like my kind of place. It's in. It'll... Oh, they're not all the same.
Unknown: Oh, you know... They all look the same. Oh, they all look the same. My friend had a chain... What's the taco cart that was at Tony's party? It's still in there. It's inside. That's where you gotta go. Tony's party store on Cedar Street. You might get shocked, you might not. But if you're lucky enough to make it to the food truck inside the store... Inside is a booth. That's crazy. I get nervous, sometimes I wait in my car.
Unknown: Because I've had some really weird interactions while I'm there. But it's worth it. I'll even talk to the crew. Sometimes. It used to be on TV. I love going there, and then they turn it over there, and it's by the Capitol too, they got one there. Oh, you know what, they moved to Hadlet. Yep, there's one in Hadlet. No, sorry. The, um... Hadlet Mart. Yeah. Right by the pharmacy. Great, great. That's way better than Alparito.
Unknown: Can I use your knife? I think you can. I'm waiting on the... I don't know, you don't need it. Sure. I don't know how the jar works. Well, yeah, it probably works. It's good. I mean, I haven't had this yet. This is good. This looks really... Oh. It's good for the meat style. We, um... Yeah, we... Because, you know, we do big family reunions, I bought a big, like, 40-pound, like, I bought those little wheels or the cones, you can see in stores, I bought them shipped from Chicago. Wow. Frozen to our house. So we've had them for family reunions, and we'll just cut them up and then fry them. Wow. It looks like this, so... It looks like the real deal.
Unknown: Do you do lamb.
Unknown: Yeah. Well, it's like a lamb mix, yeah. Mm-hmm. But yes.
Unknown: Oh, it's so good. And every year they would have refreshments, and my mom would take us every year to Zoan's wait in line, this long line to the shawarma, and we'd watch them cut it right off the thing. Was that in this area.
Unknown: There's one back in Metro Detroit, too.
Unknown: Have you ever had a cheese pizza wrapped around an Italian sausage? No. Wow. Oh.
Unknown: I had a boo. You're going to die of the smell on your face with this. Good way to go.
Unknown: Okay, guys, this is your shot with Paul. You can have more than one shot with me. You just have to ask. I literally had the whole thing on my calendar. I'm like, no one's invited me. They just said, show up for eight hours. I'm like, I'm not doing that.
Unknown: I think the biggest question was around if we had to pick different systems to own, like to be the source of truth, the source of record for data, which one is that and why? And I think... What we were thinking is what I'm hearing you say too, which is like thinking of a sourcing window, as a standalone product is really helpful where you start. And everything else is integrations. And if we can do syncs well, then it doesn't really matter too much who owns Source of Truth because the data will be available in both.
Unknown: And what I'm trying to do as much as possible architecturally is not to be, let's say, bound by the potential limitations of Salesforce. So let's build our own database with our own part numbers. Because part of what we were saying, even with vendors putting it in there too, then if you can track where the source of that part number came from, Block can decide if they want to bidirectionally sync them back to Salesforce or not. That can be a business decision, not a technical constraint, basically.
Unknown: Much of what we're facing is, are records that have more dependency within Salesforce than they do in Salesforce.
Unknown: Outside of this flow, other workflows require it. It doesn't have to be until this has got it running. Which is why I think, to Amy's point, I don't see a reason. If we're synchronizing objects back and forth, there's no reason to have any impact on phase one. You'll have to think through, are there any parts of the sourcing process that, like how many different objects are there that might be moved entirely to the new system? We'll still sync the data back and forth. But I want to kind of get that list of six to ten entity types, like object types.
Unknown: So we can kind of think through, you know, whether it's sourcing records or the parts themselves. Like, you know, vendors, going down the list, capabilities, what it's looked like to sync these back and forth. Like capabilities is a good example. Do we want that to be a self-service thing in sourcing window so that vendors can say, these are my capabilities, or is that dangerous? Like, is that, I mean, can they say, like, does that need to be verified.
Unknown: It's both. It needs to be verified to offer them the ability to initiate it.
Unknown: Got it. So, okay. I would say that would live in sourcing window, but could be synchronized to Salesforce so that CSRs on a call could see that in their context.
Unknown: I don't know if this is right or wrong. but I'm gonna make this statement anyways. When I think about sources of truth, everybody's own database is the source of truth. Because we're integrating with it. It's almost like it's just a data warehouse that things are moving through to make sure it cleanses to what my descriptions are, my materials, whatever, however I call them, right? Like, and I'm just moving through. Like, if I put a tracking number in, because I sold it to somebody else, it goes into the warehouse, the warehouse kicks it back into their database. They have the source of truth, right?
Unknown: It's the exact information that's going in there. So everybody technically has the source of truth. What gets slightly tricky is when you talk about, capabilities, okay, well, it kind of has to live here with the way it's structured. It's the power tool that we've set here. That's the source of truth of what your capabilities are. So if you don't set these correct, there's nothing I can do about that because you probably don't have capabilities in your system where you have a check mark box that like, whoa. We wouldn't, right? Like, if we look at that, we'd have to take a look at that. We'd just go into the.
Unknown: who will say, okay, this, and this.
Unknown: I guess identifying, though, which pieces of, when it changes in your system, and when it changes in Salesforce, understanding when those almost become the source of truth. Because I could see a scenario where you're like, great, I did this in the sourcing window, it comes over now in the Salesforce, and you're like, I wanna update that. The question is, how do you know when to update versus like, nope, it's in my system.
Unknown: If you go with decentralized source of truth, you're saying that you just have to deal with conflicts. If you don't have a strategy for that, it can work. This is really one of the biggest advancements in technology in the last 30 years, probably, is source control systems, how we handle source code, moved from being a single source of truth to recognizing there's some problems with that. What if every developer could have their own source control? As long as you could handle how you deal with conflicts, I know I'm getting technical here, but as long as you can handle conflicts, you and I both changed the name of this part. Which one is going to win?
Unknown: I don't know.
Unknown: Right, right, right, so you want, nope, which would allow you to essentially, we would clone it, you guys could cleanse it, and then you guys could like say, okay, let's approve or deny, and then once we denied it, let's not get asked every single time if we just do approve it.
Unknown: So let's say we scrub 5,000 part numbers outside of a bunch of OEM manuals, does that, new information, does that currently live in Block's ecosystem? Does that live in Sourcing Window or Block.
Unknown: Yeah, Sourcing Window, and then it gets asked, it says, hey Block, do you want to add this to your system? And that's, yeah, I think we could build it, or you could do it in any way.
Unknown: It could be a process that somebody has decided, all these types we do, these ones we don't, or maybe you want all, like that can be an automated process, you guys decide.
Unknown: And if you're trying to keep this as like, it's products outside of the system. Outside of Block, then yeah, put it in Block, or sorry, put it in Sourcing Window first, and then, because imagine you have this like premium vendor later. They could opt into, I want to see the whole inventory list, and then they're like, yes, no, I don't want some of those. So then you're only updating one spot next to all the others.
Unknown: This is where those customers matter, because what if, you know, new part comes into existence, vendor ends at the sourcing window at the same time within like five seconds of the site, someone adds it on your team that you sell. Now the sync process is going to come, and the question is which one to be, normally what happens is you click which one wins, and you have an audit list where you say, hey, by the way, we have this conflict, we chose this, go ahead and change it if you want. Is that manual.
Unknown: Well, if they're changing it, it could be manual, but that's where you guys decide. You would keep the rules. You would say probably block wins, but I'll put it to a list and let us know. And then it'll be like, here's the five that block already had.
Unknown: Yeah, imagine an automated process with an audit log so you could see what happened. Okay. Because if you, yeah, if you want.
Unknown: Yeah, you could be like block added it Tuesday at 5 p.m., the system added it, or tried to add it but chose not to.
Unknown: That's a big reason why we tried. That's a big one. source of truth is then it just gets simpler, but if it's worth the complexity of having multiple sources of truth, then you just deal with the complex.
Unknown: But if they're trying to have it separate, you don't want to update proc to then have sourcing window update, because your next premium vendor, you're not going to be like, oh, they want to update the parts list in sourcing window. You're going to be like, no, you can't do that. So you want to kind of create things. Yeah, I was just cool with the logic in there. It was fun. But you can automate anything and everything. Okay.
Unknown: Paul, you talked about the data warehouse a while back with Mark. Are we still, is Block doing a data warehouse? And then if so, I would expect that to impact SVP customers in particular, the premium version of SVP where there's the legal protection of data that comes into play. So how does that factor into the sourcing window.
Unknown: Isn't the data warehouse just the middle part between the tooling, Block, and the data rest? All parts.
Unknown: That's not quite, I thought that might be it, we asked Mark, Mark wants it to be a direct poll, but the truth is it can be whatever you guys want, whatever Mark decides, whatever you guys negotiate, we don't care where the source comes from, normally data warehouses are a place where you throw a bunch of data, and you can do lots of analytics and reporting off of it, they're slower, they're not transactional, but that's what they're really good at, there's tons and tons of data, that can be used for whatever purpose you want, but if you want, more like real time, that's not their normal primary use case, but we'd have our own data.
Unknown: That's what Mark was, that's what I'm thinking too, yeah, one of the reasons for that is that we can set up, we'll talk to F&B tomorrow, but we can have like very near real time transcription Salesforce stuff. That's great. Yeah. It's like we have something running around the clock just listening to Salesforce, and as soon as there's a new record, it gets added. And then same thing the other way. Yep. It's a slightly different process. Yeah. Same thing. That's those bi-directional things, yeah. But that's where, like, whether it's if Mark decides he wants us to come to the warehouse and have a little bit of time lag, we could do that.
Unknown: I just don't think that's what he was pitching earlier. Steve and I started talking about this near the end, and it's something we started to think about, the way your admin users are working, as far as what's the, I'm going to use an offensive term, fixation on keeping things in Salesforce. Like, it's like, man, it's got to be in Salesforce. And I'm like, does it really? And it sounds like, well, the biggest reason is not wanting to have too much change, and, so keeping things as consistent as possible has real value when it comes to retraining.
Unknown: Am I hearing that right? Like, early on at least, people, like we're saying for phase one, just nothing changes. Yeah. The internal users use the process they're used to right now. The risk, obviously, with that is if we add new functionality as part of MVP+, then that has to be recreated by FMD in the current process. But my hope is, moving forward, there's real value in kind of having that be more of a unified experience, whether you're internal or external, although we could have it embedded, like you're saying. The hospital system's going to want this, too.
Unknown: Having the new stuff we're building but embedded inside of Salesforce is not hard to do, if there's real value. What I think I needed you guys to tell me is, to me, it's like, if I have one tab that's Salesforce and one tab that's sourcing window, it's not a big deal. But some people, that sounds like it might be a big deal. That might feel jarring.
Unknown: It depends. Currently, the high volume that some of these people carry, they have 30 tabs open already. They absolutely do not want one more tab. They cannot function with one more tab because of the volume and the urgency of everything they carry. And it's mostly Salesforce tabs? They're all through Salesforce. Got it. They're not all through Salesforce. Sometimes we get OEM pricing. But we're logging into the GE website. or we're logging into this for the, I mean, there's, we're interfacing with a lot of different tools that aren't necessarily block tools, but they're tools that we need to do our jobs.
Unknown: Yep, got it. That's a whole other thing is there's all kinds of ways to look at that. But like, that aside, because I'm hearing about that, I'm like, man, there's integrations with real-time updating panels and really useful UIs. But for now, it's like, these guys are very good at their current problems. Certainly maybe there's a better way, but let's not worry about that right now. I think we could get to that. Yeah, yeah, but that's not my persona. I think we have to learn how they think, that's not how I take it. It doesn't allow you to either. Like, it's a little bit more procedure. So in this case, the idea is,
Unknown: they might even go to the same page, but they'll have a new thing in there now that's just a little bit better real-time updating and that kind of stuff. And then they want to click away to another tab and say, look, I can't find another browser tab. If they're in looking at the sourcing process, they want to go back to the contact. Correct. They can do that. And they'll be right inside of the same tab. That's where they, that's like a lower lift for them right now. Yeah.
Unknown: And then Amy's said this before, but the crucialness of we can't mess it up the first time because everyone opts out and disengages and is no longer willing to try.
Unknown: Is that mostly, in your guys' experience, is that admin? Past trauma. Yeah, past trauma on the internal side mostly? Yeah. I mean, it's actually...
Unknown: There's a piece that the team pushes towards internal because they don't understand the external and the limitations that we have to be able to do that. And then adding the limitation or constraint where it's like, we have to go live. Like, there was no more waiting. There was no choice. That was because of the acquisition process? Part of that going into fiscal year, it should have been done three months prior. We couldn't do it, so it was like, well, then January's the day. And there is no stopping. And so the team's not understanding the why behind that.
Unknown: They're like, why would you make my life miserable? All of these other things we have to. Like, it's not... The business has to do that. And so I would say as the fixation of Salesforce is, if you are 100% sure it's gonna be less clicks and faster and better, you can make whatever change you want.
Unknown: Yeah. Okay. It's really user experience is the driver.
Unknown: It is. So you could literally fundamentally change everything knowing we're going in that direction. If you present it and it makes their life easier, everybody will be on board. You do not have to worry about the fact that, is it in Salesforce? I would even argue they would be willing to open up another tab if it was that much better.
Unknown: It was that much better that they could go boom. There's so much them, even walking through the checkout today, I was just like, man, so much of this is in the document. So much of this they're having to do every single time.
Unknown: And this is where the past trauma thing comes in because that was over two years ago where we had to go live, right? And there are teams that you saw today, doing that 50 times a day.
Unknown: And it's not finished yet. Yeah, that blows my mind.
Unknown: The process never got, they never came back to finish it. And most departments can say that about some parts of their process, right? So when you say.
Unknown: did it not get finished because budget.
Unknown: But you've got, like, time. It's still time.
Unknown: It's still, yeah.
Unknown: It's the importance of what's there. So when you have a service delivery model that isn't working to be able to go from take a call to deliver service versus my parts team has to put things in four times, I'm going to pick I'm going to fix my service delivery problem. And the team understands that, actually. It's just super annoying. And I'm just tired of it. It's been two years. And they're mine. And if I could do back, do all this all over again, Sourcing Window Pro never would have been put in the sales force. And it actually, and again, this is the way it was designed, it cost us the first three months,
Unknown: no, four months of launch to fix Sourcing Window to get it that we couldn't work on the other things in the organization because it was taking up so many hours on what had to fundamentally be fixed. We had three people.
Unknown: That's it. It's a fix. So it sounds like eventually getting, like, talking to some of the individuals.
Unknown: the individuals that are doing the admin pieces, I mean, it really helps. Oh, yeah.
Unknown: Yeah, yeah, yeah. my brain works yeah as far as like they're like i've seen that kind of they're clicking around they're really even though it's 20 clicks they're probably used to it yeah they're just like i need my seven yeah it's like even that i've seen and people in that space and we interview something different but better there's a way to do it right well you bring them along you like.
Unknown: run it in parallel you like show you get a couple beta users to then teach the rest of the team.
Unknown: yeah yeah find out what their their biggest pain points are right right.
Unknown: i mean that's that's some of the hopes too.
Unknown: i think i do better with like meals as like grazer and like snacking i might do better with six meals a day a bit of a hub setter.
Unknown: such a. No, I think we had a duel. Oh, they just came to see you. Yeah, I think we did. So I took the board. You're terrible.
Unknown: I'm so sorry. Yes, that's the other way. I did not. With a smile on your face.
Unknown: I actually did not. Unfortunately, I did not. I chose not to. That's why part of me is almost saying we need to stop talking about phase two. We're just three right now. Because there is a lot. It's not that there's not a lot. But if we can focus on phase one and get that ironed out for the next 24 hours. My fear right now is we're just getting buried by all the million things that we're not even touching. Phase two and three gap. So let's focus on phase one externally. Let's make that amazing. Because FMD tomorrow, we need to be hitting them with questions of timeline.
Unknown: We looked at the Excel sheet you sent over with more detailed requirements. There's like 118 of them. Some of those were like do nots. What is it? Can you hit the top here? They do not like, on the SRC records, you have like, I don't want to hit the same one. You said something about not wanting to hit the same one. And so when I put it in the fridge, I will look at it and I'll be in the eyes. Your face is telling me I gotta sing it right. Okay, no, I'm sure you're singing it right and I'm just not remembering what I wrote. You know, something about, on the SRC records specifically, you don't want to have to hit cancel or something like that. You want that to be automatic.
Unknown: or what's the thought process behind it? That's a very detailed thing. And I think they'll have to log it in, because there are times where you're done, you've submitted it, and like, what do you do now? Like, you would have to press cancel or save or the X. Like, cancel doesn't do anything, it refreshes the page. Save doesn't say submit, it's not a call to action. You don't know what you're doing when you press that button. And so you have to click the X. So there's certain things like that, where it's like, just going out. If you were to rebuild it, just like what we have, like, do not build it, just like what we have.
Unknown: In your opinion, would you... Oh yeah, I was not like... This is kind of a loaded question, Barry. Would you prefer, as we are trying to recreate the new flow, would you like us to slow down, and go through the current flow and make it better? Or would you like us to reimagine that flow.
Unknown: You're saying for phase one.
Unknown: For, yes, external buyer, external vendor. Because we can take what you currently have and make it work better. Or we can reimagine.
Unknown: I mean, I hate to not reimagine. We have the opportunity to reimagine, right.
Unknown: Yeah. We always reimagine, and then we give feedback.
Unknown: Yeah, yeah. Okay.
Unknown: So it's like, what are the tasks these people are showing up to do? Yeah. And then how can we do it? Yeah, yeah, yeah. What steps do we think? And then there's the back and forth exchange. Because I think that kind of thing you just mentioned would need to come up. Yeah. Because Jake was making the idea.
Unknown: Right. Which is so true. And also, we talk about past traumas a lot. Our past team built verbatim what we asked for, but we had to create the solution to ask for it. And that's where we really sold ourselves short. Because I am not a designer. I don't know. I mean, I can come up with a really awful idea of what could be a potential solution, and they'll build it just for me. like what I said, and so they did their job, right? But it sucked, right? And so I would love for you, absolutely, to be like, that's stupid, here's one awesome idea that we could try,
Unknown: because that's, we are gonna fall short. That's what I need to see. And now I would like to draw that. The man in the beginning. Any of those requirements that don't make sense, just let me know, because I'll probably have to, like, jump into where I was in that thought process. And then I found going back and forth with some of the other developers during the bid process.
Unknown: Oh, F&D. F&D, yeah. What should we know about them going in? Because I know nothing about F&D, like. Nice, okay. We need, essentially, a lot of what we're going to be doing. We're going to be very reliant on, hey, we are going to do something that you guys need to integrate into it, or you guys can do it, like, expose a thing so that we can integrate into it. And if those timelines are missed, we'll have to create our own, essentially, like, data, which is fine, but it pulls us back from potentially hitting our target.
Unknown: of real data. What's your experience been with their timelines? Are they an on-time team.
Unknown: When engaged with appropriate timelines, yes, they can hit whatever you need. Michael does a great job from an enterprise level working through projects. Jeff is the most creative of the group and knows what's available, of what's there. And then there's some newer team members I'm not sure, like Akshay. And then who's the other guy that you talked about? Alex. Alex. Those two I'm just not as familiar with their capability.
Unknown: We also have to make sure Mark is consistent so that Mark can make sure that he is bringing up the bandwidth and having them prioritize new features for the sake of this.
Unknown: So I think having them part of that conversation push there, because at the end of the day he's going to have to be the one to say, don't work on that, work on this.
Unknown: Because we're hoping to get to a point where we can map out essentially everything. that we can give them real targets. I just don't know if do we need to give them two weeks before we actually type targets.
Unknown: I mean, if I can have anything on the front, it would be as once you've gone through discovery and saying, if I plan this out, this would be our hope of this happens this, this happens this, this happens this. Let's have a meeting, here's what it is. We will keep you up to date on what questions do you have. Okay, boom, and then you're gonna be fine. Jeff almost said he used to work for Block Imaging as a project manager, then redeveloped and did SAP for us. SAP B1 development, then he broke off on his own, then he came back.
Unknown: Obviously they were inside of team members of Block Imaging before it split. So you have some people that like, They know Block really well. They feel part of it. And the other piece, just to keep in the back of your head is they wanted to redo this thing. They knew they shouldn't, because of other conditions. Other commitments and other things, to accomplish and do, and so they stepped out of the bid process, saying, nope, you guys should do this with another vendor. For Jeff, though, because it was his baby in the first Salesforce, there is a piece.
Unknown: that he's like, oh, I wanted to do this so bad, so bad. Yep, I get that. So there's just going to be a little bit, you just need to know that little bit of, know that super attention.
Unknown: Do you think they had, are they focused on Salesforce, or do they have a breadth of technology.
Unknown: Most of their team knows Salesforce. Jeff knows pretty much anything I've ever asked, heard about, he knows about it. And then I would say, actually, Alex, I don't think, I think they know some Salesforce, but they actually are other platforms. Alex is more of a front-end web developer. Yeah, could be. So, yeah, their big thing in what they're developing with their ConvoPro AI piece, it's pretty cool. Yeah. It's pretty cool.
Unknown: Cool. And how it integrates with just, it's agnostic. And you're just doing anything.
Unknown: Yeah, that'll be fun to see what the plan is to integrate that with the sourcing window. I mean, if it's... It has to be. Yeah, for sure. I'm curious, like, what is it good at? What does the integration look like? Is it like a chat kind of on the side? I don't even know much about it. But you guys, what can you tell me about it.
Unknown: It's not a chat bot. Okay. Is it like a, yeah, what is it? It's just like things you can just search. Well, it depends on what you want to do. They're working to build it so it integrates, where you could just have it laying inside of it. Like an assistant, you just ask a question. Got it, okay. And that's all that data. And that's what they're trying to get to. If it's presenting itself, it will go into data. What do you want to ask it? And then, or prompt buttons or automations in the background that, you know, AI can really do some things to help. Yeah. Some things for, like, invoice automation, right? Yep.
Unknown: A PDF comes in, it reads it, and outputs it into whatever fields you want. Right? So you could say that from a FedEx label. Just like a FedEx label goes in, it goes and reads it, it outputs it. And all you had to do was just upload the FedEx label of what's there and it read it for you. I don't know. I'm making it up. Yeah, yeah. I'm trying to talk you around.
Unknown: I actually realized I was at Spectrum Health the same time that Michael was. So we went over laps. I was heading up the portal process and he was working on Salesforce. And our team used Salesforce. So there's a decent chance we, like, didn't even know we were in the same circle. Yeah, that's cool. That's funny. And Jeff's been already really helpful in just answering a few questions. So we'll definitely be really careful. I know what it's like to build something and then want to do that V2 and not be able to do it. I've done that in the Fed for you.
Unknown: And I would suggest that the moment you're ready to present, I'd take Mark Baker. And they're literally across the street. Oh, they are. Like, go across the parking lot. There you go. You're there. You're at their building. And just think, hey, we want to come talk about this together. Yeah, yeah. And we'll be in at different occasions. Like, okay, if there's reasons for you to jump in, pop on over. We don't have a problem with that. Watch what we're doing. Here's what it is. I think the more invitation you give, the easier it becomes. Good. Yeah. Are they remote tomorrow, or are they joining? We don't know how to do this. Jeff is in Pennsylvania.
Unknown: Oh, and... Is he Pennsylvania or New York? He's New York. East of here. Anybody need a box? Yeah, we'll grab one soon. No, but I haven't been eating in nine minutes.
Unknown: Well, it's part of your thing. Yeah, go for it. If I give it to you, it's not stealing. I've known Nate for long enough that I could have stolen it without asking. But he did have his eye on it. I knew. I was like, Nate, you're not getting it.
Unknown: Not now. I'm done. This is really good. This was a good pita, by the way. Good pita, good meat. The pita's great. And I don't know if you can tell, but Nate's Greek. I don't know if you can tell, but... My kids look absolutely nothing like me, it's crazy. My wife's blond hair, blue eyed. All my kids are blond hair, blue eyed. None of this came through. That's crazy, yeah. That's like the dominant team. Yes, my dad has blue eyes, so it came through. How tall is Jim? 6'1". You're going to be the shortest person in the family. Could be. I'm trying to make it easier for my kids to be taller than me.
Unknown: Not so bad about it. I shouldn't. It's great. They're already tall for their age.
Unknown: Talk about the shame. Jovi, our oldest, had soccer this weekend. She's like in the 90's percentile for height. Everyone always says she's huge. You just don't realize it. She's around kids her age. I'm like, wow, she's like a head above me. It's just wild. Which comes with some pros and cons. People think she's older than she is. I feel that all the time. I was like, he's a tall 5 year old.
Unknown: I don't know how to tell you that. It's just your expectations.
Unknown: Steve, truly, if you just send me a team message and you're like, hey, we're talking about something, can you pop up? I'll tell you.
Unknown: And then I can just pop up as soon as I possibly can. She's 10 now, and she's like, perfect. She's the size of the same as mine. She's just like a big kid, you know? Nothing wrong with that, but dance was not her thing. She was always very self-conscious. And then we put her in basketball, and this girl just stands under the hoop and rebounds. She doesn't like to run. She doesn't like to work hard. She's kind of like, man. But she just sits there, and everyone just passes her the ball. She's just like, yep, this is where I'm going to go.
Unknown: It's all about where you go, you know? Yes. My daughter is also tall, but her cousin is extremely tall. And her cousin's fantastic at ballet, because she's extremely short. But she's small, yeah. So I'm trying to even... Oh, that's perfect. Thank you. Are you going to give us four of these if you want one.
Unknown: Yeah, I'll take four. I'll take four. I can't get more. Oh, Vicki, do you want a box, too? You have more than I do, so I can squeeze into the small one. I can squeeze a small one in mine.
Unknown: I'll just hold it. I'll take the small one. Yeah, I'll take it. It's fine. Here you go. Yeah, you're going back. But anyways, we're trying to convince her.
Unknown: Yes, that would be good gold.
Unknown: Your height is a big advantage, though. Your wife played volleyball? Yeah. That's a good, she's fifth. Actually, I have to know, because we were measuring for a water park. She's like 52 inches at six, so she'll be seven soon. Okay. So I am really tall. She's 16 now, and she's almost 5'10". Wow. What? That's tall. That was kind of my wife. Well, yeah, so right here she's the tall one. She powers over me. Oh.
Unknown: I don't know. I've always been like her, like, second grade. She reached a certain age, and she said to me, and he was like, you've been picking fights with her, but I just want you to know. that she's the first to meet you. Yeah. So what dance studio did you guys go to.
Unknown: Studio H? Yeah. It's in... Can you say that again? Oh, yeah. It is. It's right across the street. On Cedar Street, actually. In between Willow and Mason. It's really close to the block. Down the street? Down the street towards Mason. On the left hand side. Oh, is it right over by? The Journey Church? Yeah, yeah. The Black and White Cookies? Yup. Chocolate, Bobcat? Well, my youngest will probably be back because she loves it.
Unknown: But we moved her out because it was very intense, like competitive, like the culture there is just like... Do you like the people?
Unknown: My kids have been back here for the last few years. It's been a while.